Make a hole in the top,
make a hole in the top, and make a hole in the top.What are you going to do?I've got hands, but I'm going to
frighten them and push them into the depths.I
want to leave it to you, the great Baron, to reign in the White Garden.  I
'll accept your request and come back. I don't care. I do
n't think Orkbolg will use the scroll again. I do
n't have the scroll. So what should I do? Go
ahead and
use some ice magic when the spell in the tunnel wears off.  If you do that, the ice will
swell and your behavior will break down during the season.Okay, I get it.Then all you have to do is
find a burrow from the ground and smash it
down.I'll do that for you, but I'm tired.Next
time, I'll call you for a non-goblin adventure.But
please, I'll take a look at the pond.  I knew it was below, because
Shirodono had been here before, so a long
time ago, a long time ago.